we're learning new information about the
daily lives of undocumented children
being held in the government centers
video provided by the government shows
that tensity in Tornillo texas housing
more than 300 teenagers it cost about
seven hundred dollars a day for a child
to care for them Matea V ADL toured the
facility yesterday and she met parents
who were still looking for their
children she's near the border in El
Paso that's just northwest of Tonio
mateo good morning well good morning we
spoke with a number of parents here in
El Paso that were recently released from
detention some of them haven't seen
their children in over a month and
despite what the government is saying
they have no idea when they will be
reunited again Eadie's tells us she was
separated from her six-year-old son
after they crossed the border she
believes he's in Arizona
she says she's tried several times to
try and talk to her son and that has not
been Edie's was released from a
detention center and is one of 30 to
immigrant parents staying at the
Annunciation House in El Paso the
average length of this time that the
parents have been in detention was 25
days taylor levy is the legal
coordinator of Annunciation house 91
percent of the families the parents who
we spoke to have not personally spoken
to their children since being separated
we toured a tent city in Tornillo Texas
Monday where 326 teenagers are being
housed our cameras were not allowed
inside but the government provided this
video we learned children spend their
day on a regimented military-style
schedule they eat three meals a day and
are given two snacks many of them spend
their free time playing soccer
the Tornillo facility has been open for
nearly two weeks and in that time the
Department of Health and Human Services
tells us 70 children have been released
to family or sponsors we've established
where the parents are almost immediate
the childís comes into our care Mark
Weber is with HHS overall these kids are
connected with their parents but
Annunciation House director Ruben Garcia
disagrees I have 32 parents here that
will say to him that is categorically
untrue
federal authorities dismissed criminal
charges against that entire group of 32
for illegal entry although they still
have their immigration cases pending now
the incident commander at the Tornillo
tent facility says that that facility is
solely in existence because of the
separation policy he says it was a dumb
stupid decision that should have never
been made great reporting there Maria
thank you